I'll tell you the drug right now the
drug of my choice is gratitude I grew up
with very little but I was very happy I
know that happiness is not
money I'm grateful for everything I have
not the fancy things I have now
everything the thing I'm most grateful
for is the people I love are healthy
after that I can control everything else
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
fully fresh pot of gumbo and we back up
on our bowling money shout out to the
boy cooking I'm everything our cubby
shades on with a hoodie
hi guys
such a pleasure how are you it's been a
long day
you're welcome we should help you with
that yes yes I got it
there's so much
foreign
[Music]
as you start becoming thoughtful you
realize why you're like you are genetics
environment parenting and then people
get stuck because then they get into
blaming the longer you're in blame mode
the longer you have no chance of getting
out and what people struggle with is
they don't realize that forgiveness
doesn't mean that it didn't happen when
you forgive somebody it doesn't mean
that they didn't do wrong it just means
that you've unlocked yourself to be able
to grow a lot of times people think when
you forgive someone it excuses what they
did forgiving is opening up a path for
yourself
thank you
so like this time like we set it up as
like Harry and you like kind of toxic
you know fire chat sessions beautiful
and then they they're gonna ask some
questions after that too perfect
glad we're here
[Applause]
I'll tell you the drug right now the
drug of my choice is gratitude I grew up
with very little but I was very happy I
know that happiness is not
money I'm grateful for everything I have
not the fancy things I have now
everything the thing I'm most grateful
for is the people I love are healthy
after that I can control everything else
you know
it's true that's true
[Music]
I think the most important thing to
teach is the elimination of fear I think
fear is the biggest poison to children I
think parents use fear on children to
make them do what they want and so I do
think critical thinking is incredibly
important but I think if you were able
to build self-esteem confidence and if
you're able to have your child not be
scared to fail then you will have a very
happy child you have to understand life
is too complex
to think there's a right answer people
think they're going to make the right
decision you have no idea how it's going
to work out you just don't know you
really don't know and so for all of us
whether it's University or having
children or moving once you make a
decision you can't dwell on that
decision anymore you have no idea how
that would have changed your life
everything in your life is different
forever and we should look at it
optimistically not pessimistically
thank you so much
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was a perfect way to end it all
right see if it's lover won everything
touch my soul touch my heart don't judge
my mental they told me that life is
simple been real since pop a pimple I
love Tokyo like my first real meaningful
trip here anything that has a New York
Vibe is always going to play for me what
I think New York has over a lot of
places is the cool Street part and I
think I mean in a lot of ways Tokyo has
that in spades
[Music]
thank you
I know you're gonna recently talking a
lot about intuition I have I'm really
passionate about this I really think
that there's a lot of things we
understand today that we did in 100
years ago around the body around modern
science and things of that nature I like
really started to realize like so much
of what's happening is happening here
and I'm like how many more of you like
get feelings from your stomach your gut
your intuition
Society is telling you like that's silly
that's stupid that can't be right you
don't do that like crush your teeth dot
your eyes make the logical decision I
can sense inside of me that this thing
talks to me but this thing talks to me
and I'm not sure that's like a normal
conversation today I am like will
continue more and more to like listen to
this and I think I have been like it's
why I keep ending up in the right places
if it was logical everyone would be
there you know like YouTube in 2006 like
if it was logical everybody would be
there a lot of that was
the world didn't exist the way we know
it today
foreign